Okay.
So we're going to continue to be with
our initial exploration of different
ways to see the world.
And so the last time I talked to you a
little bit about,
um,
perceptions of what you might describe
as action orientation.
So the case I made for you with
something like this,
that there's two significant patterns of
facts in the sense that you need to know
about the world and one has to do with
the object,
the reality of things.
And the other has to do with how you
configure your behavior in the face of
that objective reality.
And those two overlap to some degree,
but a lot of what scientists would
normally consider subjective experiences
are part of the domain that is
applicable to how you comport yourself
or how you act,
not the moral domain.
Um,
because psychology,
especially in its clinical
manifestations,
is concerned with how people should act,
which is in part mental health and how
they should perceive.
And even experimental psychology to some
degree is concerned with
psychopathology.
It's necessary to account for the
subjective and also for values as you
move forward in your investigation of,
of psychology,
personality psychology or clinical
psychology.
So,
MMM,
I want to,
we,
we started last week talking a little
bit about mythological representations,
um,
which I think of as the precursor to a
lot of the clinical theories that we're
going to cover today.
I want to go into that in a little bit
more detail and with a little bit more
specificity because I want to talk to
you about shamanic initiations and other
rights of initiation because it's
appeared to me for a long time and this
is,
this is something that has also been
observed by psychoanalytic thinkers,
that there are a
relevant and important points of
similarity between these archaic rituals
and the sorts of things that people
undergo in psychotherapy.
So I can give you a brief example and
then we'll,
we'll,
we'll consider this in more detail.
Okay.
People learn almost everything they
learned that's important in the face of
fear.
And although that's slightly more pests,
pessimistic viewpoint than it might be
because you can optimize that.
The rate at which you expose yourself to
things that would otherwise cause you to
be afraid,
then they tend just to captivate you
would make you intensely interested.
So,
but as you're progressing through life,
what you're doing continually as either
at interacting with things that you
understand well,
which means that you know how to behave
in the face up or your interactions with
things that you don't understand at all.
And your body and your mind are prepared
to respond to things that you don't
understand it all.
And they basically respond by putting
you on alert and being on alert is it
signed from your,
from the deep unconscious recesses of
your mind and your body for that matter
that you don't know what you're doing in
this particular space.
And as a consequence you have more
things to learn.
And so the way you learn when you're in
town or something that you don't
understand is by progressing voluntarily
into the space and time that's unknown.
And so you're always learning as a
consequence of facing the unknown.
And the unknown is something that can be
frightening.
Although it can also be interesting if
you,
if you calibrate your exposure property.
Now this is just as true for
psychotherapy as it is for any other
form of learning.
And that's because psychotherapy really
is a form of guided and structured
learning.
One of the things that you continually
do with people who are seeking
psychotherapeutic health is to determine
what it is that they're afraid of or
what it is that they don't understand.
And then to break it down into what you
might describe as manageable doses and
then get people to expose themselves to
that situation or set of situations
voluntarily.
And the consequence of that is that
people become less afraid and more able.
And the original hypothesis was that was
because you were doing some form of
counter conditioning that people have
learned to be afraid in a particular
circumstance and you were teaching them
to not be afraid.
That's wrong.
That viewpoint.
What you're really doing with people
when you expose them to situations that
they're afraid of or that they don't
understand is expanding the range of
competence,
and you either do that by literally
teaching them how to behave in those
circumstances,
which is what you would do with children
or maybe with friends or by helping them
observe their own reactions when they're
placed in a situation like that.
Because lots of people who are afraid of
things think that when they confront
something they're afraid of voluntarily,
that there'll be absolutely terrified
and unable to cope,
but they often find that if they do
place himself in a situation carefully
and voluntarily,
that they're nowhere near as paralyzed
by the encounter as they might've
thought.
And so art and what you're teaching them
then is that there's more to them than
they thought.
Generally,
when you're teaching people about the
world,
given that the world is a frightening
place,
if you're a psychotherapist,
there isn't a lot of utility in trying
to convince people that the world isn't
as dangerous as they think because the
world is just as dangerous as you think
it is.
It's actually quite a remarkable fact
that we're all not paralyzed with
anxiety all the time,
but what we're not.
But part of what you have in your
armament against the terrorism of the
world is the possibility that you hold
within you and people are unbelievably
tough and resourceful creatures.
And even if you think that you're not up
to the challenge,
you can be sure that encoded in your
bodily structures somewhere,
our abilities that you don't really
understand that would come to the
forefront if you put yourself in a
situation where they were necessary.
So,
and that's a lot of psychotherapy is
precisely that.
It's helping the person learn that
there's more to them and they fake not
so much that the world is less
frightening.
So
there
to be exposed to something you're afraid
of often means to reconfigure your own
preconceptions.
Because if you're afraid of something,
it usually means that you coded it or
understand it in a certain way.
And so that when you encounter it,
not only do you have to learn something
new,
but you also have to let go of your old
presuppositions.
Maybe that's what you do.
For example,
if you overcome some kind of prejudice
that you might have to,
to people or things or places because
you don't,
you don't approach the,
the,
the object that you're afraid of in a
conceptual vacuum and you have
presuppositions.
And what that also applies is that when
you're learning,
even when you're learning incrementally,
there's a process of letting go and a
process of building.
So when you learn something new,
you have to let go of an old
presupposition of some sort.
And those precept positions are alive
because they're part of view.
Part of what that means is that every,
every element of learning in the face of
something novel is often also an undoing
of previous learning.
And that's partly why the Motif of death
and rebirth is such a powerful one
through,
throughout human history.
It's a primary motive of human.
Um,
what would you call it,
of the human story.
It certainly of human mythology and the,
the experiences that people have in
psychotherapy are often similar to death
and rebirth experiences in part because
they come in damaged and fragmented and
hurt and often have to encounter even
more of the material that caused the
trouble to begin with.
But the consequence of that is that they
can shake the structures that are
inhibiting their further development
even though that might cause some pain
and then hopefully they can come back
alive.
And you know that when you encounter
something that's truly unknown,
you go through a process that's similar
to that too,
in that if you,
if you,
if you've ever been in a situation,
for example,
where you deeply desired something
but you failed to get it for one reason
or another,
there's a tremendous amount of pain
associated with that.
That could be a person or,
or a goal or a dream or something like
that.
It's extraordinarily painful not to be
able to attain a valued goal.
And the failure generally produces,
literally produces pain.
It's,
it's,
it's cognitive pain,
but many of the same pathways that are
involved.
And when you have to give up something
that you value,
you're giving up a part of yourself,
the part of yourself that's predicated
on that,
on that vision.
And not only is that painful,
but it can really throw you for a loop.
Um,
the phenomena that we're going to talk
about today are
representations of that process as well
as attempts to experiment with because
people have known for a very,
very long time that there was something
about partial death and rebirth that was
also akin to the revivification of the
human spirit.
And that's noise that human beings have
had for we really don't know how long
it,
certainly tens of thousands of years and
it might be longer than that.
So that's what we're going to talk about
today.
Now I'm going to back up a little bit
and clarify some of the things that we
talked about in the last class.
So I want to give you some sense of why
people see the world the way they do
because as,
as materialistic people.
And by that I mean people who are
embedded in a conceptual world whose
primary presupposition is that?
The fundamental mental level of reality
is material.
We have some misconceptions about our
own perceptions.
So for example,
for creatures like us who are alive and
who are primates,
the objective world isn't the primary
target of our perception.
The social world is the primary target
of our perception.
Now,
that's not so surprising.
Even if you examine your own behaviors.
So you might think,
how much time do you spend during the
day interacting with people in one form
or another?
If you include texting and emailing and
phoning and face to face conversation,
or if you're not interacting with them
directly,
you're thinking about them or you're
watching them or listening to them.
So maybe you're watching them in a
movie.
Are you watching them on tv or you know,
listening to them sing or you're
watching them perform.
The point is,
is that most of the world that confronts
us is the world of other human beings.
And the world of other human beings has
been around us evolutionarily ever since
there have been human beings and it's
very difficult to pinpoint.
The precise moment in time in human
beings came into existence.
But there were certainly vaguely human
like things 2 million years ago.
We seem to have split from the common
ancestors of chimpanzees 7 million years
ago.
So it's somewhere between two and 7
million years that we've been in an
environment that's primarily made up of
other people.
And then there's a great pre history
before that if tens of millions of
years,
where are the animals that surrounded us
word precisely human.
But they were certainly social and they
were primates.
And so even stretching that back past
far past when we,
we're human,
we lived in an environment that was
fundamentally characterized by social
interactions and what that,
what that means is that our brain is
essentially set up to perceive the world
through a Social Lens.
So here,
here's a,
here's a quote from a paper on private
social cognition.
How this is,
this is a group of researchers are
trying to understand,
uh,
the prodo linguistic representations.
I think with this paper of baboons,
cause the idea would be before human,
our human ancestors have language,
they have the perceptual structures in
the conceptual structures that were
linguistic light that that language
emerged out.
And,
and,
and the,
the understanding that we eventually
trends for,
to language was there and it's
prototypical form prior to our ability
to audit.
I can give you an example of that.
It's kind of a funny example.
You know,
how many of you know what to syndrome
is?
Yeah.
How many don't?
Okay.
Well Tourette's syndrome is a syndrome.
It's neurological syndrome that's
characterized,
oddly enough,
quite the propensity to curse.
And so it's very strange because you'd
wonder how in the world with a
neurological condition can make you
curse it.
Also people with and also move.
They have motor tics and so they,
they'll move in stereotyped fashions
and,
and they really can't control that.
So if they're concentrating on
something,
they can control their motor output.
But if their concentration wanes,
then they're often possessed by fairly
complicated motor processes that sort of
run independently of their will as well
as these vocalizations.
Now you might think,
how in the world could you have a
neurological disorder that would make
you curse,
that would make you swear?
It just doesn't make sense in some sense
that your brain would be so fractionated
and it's specialization that you know
that a neurological condition could
emerge.
That was that specific.
But,
but here it seems to be the answer.
Um,
most curse words are very,
very short and kind of guttural.
And there are usually four letters as,
as in the famous four letter word.
And they're also usually expressed
during conditions of high emotion.
Now it turns out that certain kinds of
primates have distress calls.
So for example,
um,
perhaps there's a monkey troop and one
of its primary enemies are,
you know,
predatory birds that swooped down from
the sky.
And so the monkeys have evolved a cry
that basically means look out,
there's a,
there's an eagle in the sky that's going
to eat you.
And then once that cry is admitted by
any of any of the group members,
all of them immediately scatter and take
defensive action.
They high,
or maybe they have this,
it's another troupe and maybe they're
preyed on by leopards or something like
that.
And they also have an alarm pri for the
leopards.
And that means,
you know,
hit the trees or do whatever you have to
do to get away from the leopard.
Well,
it turns out that the linguistic centers
that are in those monkeys that produced
the alarm,
Christ of predators are the same
circuits that you use to curse.
And if you have tourette syndrome,
what happens is it's those old crow
linguistic circuits that you share with
lower order primates that are
disinhibited.
And so you can see a good example there
of a pro prototypic language structure
because monkeys are complicated enough
to be able to say something like,
Holy Shit,
there's a Jaguar.
And it's usually the most nervous monkey
in the path who's always jittery ground
on hyper alert,
who manages to curse out of warranty.
And so,
so anyways,
you have this protocol.
Linguistic is underlying prodo
linguistic capability.
That's,
that's,
that's at least part perceptual and so
we know,
for example,
that primates,
and this is true for animals that are
way less sophisticated,
the primates are very good at social
cognition,
so they know,
they know to the individual exactly what
strata the other members of their group
occupy can imagine they're in a dominant
Sarky,
right?
There's,
there's the,
the talk primates in the bottom primates
and then there's strategy primates all
the way up.
Just like there is in most animals and
primates are unbelievably good at
knowing who's who and they need to be.
Because if you've messed with the high
order primate up,
the dominants arc and you're sorta
lowly,
you're going to get hurt and it's,
it's better to be lowly and know your
place,
or at least this is how animals manage
it than it is to get hurt.
Young males who are sort of climbing up
the heart hierarchy will often take an
awful lot of abuse trying to get to the,
to the peak.
But most animals in his social truth are
pretty much resigned to their locale
because it's safer to be there.
And often the casts,
so to speak,
in the primate hierarchy are actually
hereditary.
So generation to generation,
the same family,
so to speak,
occupied the same rungs.
So one of the things we know about
social cognition is that,
and and human cognition is,
is that it involves social processing
and that it's also very much focused on
status.
There's some very funny studies of this
sort of thing.
I think one was done with mechanics,
if I remembered correctly,
where they'd show me the cacs
photographs of other mechanics from
their troop.
And those photographs are either have
low status mcats or of high status sort
of celebrity mechanics.
And the mechanics would spend much
longer time gazing at the high status
celebrity mechanics than like the low
people,
creatures,
whatever have you that they,
you know,
had nothing but contempt for.
So you can think a lot of our
preexisting,
perceptual and conceptual categories are
social,
so we're always processing other
creatures.
Humans for sure,
but other living creatures as well.
And we're also very concerned with who's
doing what to who and when and who's got
the power because it turns out that
dominance hierarchy status for example,
is unbelievably important in
determining,
well reproductive opportunities in
particular,
but also also general health and access
to prime access to resources.
Unbelievably important.
The internal representations of language
meaning evolve partly from our pre
linguistic ancestor's knowledge of
social relations member and when we tell
stories or listened to stories,
they're always about social relations.
So all the time like modern monkeys and
apes are ancestors,
lived in groups,
intricate networks of relationships that
were similar caneously competitive and
cooperative.
The demands of social life,
creating selective pressures for just
the kind of complex,
abstract,
conceptual and computational abilities
that are likely to have proceeded.
The earliest forms of linguistic
communication.
Although baboons have concepts and
acquire propositional information from
other animals,
vocalizations,
they cannot articulate this information.
They understand dominants relations and
matrilineal kinship,
but have no words for them.
This suggests that the internal
representation of Benny concepts,
relations and action sequences does not
require language and the language did
not evolve because it was uniquely
suited to representing thought.
Well,
you know,
as I mentioned to you in the last class
or maybe the previous class,
not only do monkeys,
baboons say,
what's your very complex?
Not only are they able to track
dominance hierarchy structures without
language like the lobsters are able to
do it.
So you can be very,
you can be very,
very sure that the underlying basis for
the linguistic representation of social
interactions is it's deep beyond belief
since we share it with crustaceans.
So it's very useful to know this because
it,
it also helps understand why certain
things have to intrinsic meaning,
you know,
like the dominance hierarchy and the
position in the dominants hurricane,
the relative status of preachers isn't
intrinsically meaningful piece of
information to us because it's an
important determinant of our survival
and reproductive opportunities.
So the meeting is there.
You don't have to learn it.
You just have to figure out what to map
it onto and that,
that means that that kind of meaning
status related meeting is art.
It's built into you as a,
as,
as the ground of understanding.
So then I'll show you something.
Hopefully this'll work.
Um,
be a miracle for work.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this,
watch this.
Okay.
So we'll watch it one more time.
So anybody willing to hazard a guess
about what was happening there?
Yeah,
it was an attack.
That's,
that's one hypothesis.
Yes.
Anyone else?
Let's,
let's look at the players once again.
Well,
so the poor little pink circle is
trapped and then it's trying to get out
and when it does get out the big gray
triangles,
shepherds in the way,
but that irritates the blue triangle,
which he shepherds it back into the box
and the gray triangle isn't able to
answer something like that.
You can tell a story about it.
Does that,
I don't know,
like I'm not saying that's the canonical
interpretation of the triangles behavior
or any of that.
But you would agree,
I presumed that that's a reasonably
plausible interpretation of what those
triangles and circles were up to you.
Yes.
Okay.
Well No,
right cause they're triangles and
circles.
But the point is,
the point is,
is that our,
our ability to perceive social
interactions is so deep that we can take
entities that are only living in so far
as they're moving in certain ways.
And we immediately attribute like
motivation to tell a little story about,
and we can also agree on the story.
Now you could say,
well it was sort of built in by the
people who made the little animated
demonstration but,
but that,
that doesn't matter because the point is
they were able to build it in without,
with,
with virtually no representation
whatsoever.
It communicate it because they,
they knew that we understand that sort
of information.
So,
okay.
All right.
So let's push our luck and see if this
works.
Well,
you get the basic idea.
So
there's a couple of things that are
interesting about that clip.
One is everything's animated.
Everything has a life.
And that's actually okay.
You can watch that and you understand
it,
which is quite strange because of course
generally trees don't dance around and
so forth,
but,
but the,
the,
this module that we have,
so to speak,
it's badly of describing it because
it's,
it's more like an entire mode.
It's the entire mode of human perception
has been called the hyperactive agency
detector by people who are somewhat
skeptical about its operation.
But,
um,
because we're evolved to exist within
living environments,
it's very living,
dynamic,
animal oriented environments.
It's very easy for us to see everything
in that way.
Everything is alive,
a priority.
And that's why when you're reading
stories to your kids,
like Thomas,
the tank engine has,
you know,
what personality and motivations and so
does the little engine that could and
all of these things that,
that,
that are used to represent to children,
ways of interacting in the world.
So,
all right.
So the,
the point of all this basically is that
we've evolved to categorize the world
into social categories and the social
categories that we use
or that use us.
That's,
that's a more accurate way of looking at
it because these are tools that we
voluntarily use.
These are ways that we perceive the
world.
They're underneath our understanding,
their preconditions for our
understanding.
So we tend to parse up the world into
personified categories.
And I didn't even say that property
exactly because that implies that you're
projecting something onto the world.
This personification.
It's deeper than that.
It's that the world appears to you
naturally end up in a,
in a living and animated manner.
And the reason for that is because most
of what you process,
and this was certainly the case
in to a great degree before human beings
became technologically proficient
because we weren't that good at
manipulating the objective world at all.
Everything that we thought about,
everything we did essentially was
dependent on other creatures.
And so what that also means is that
whatever advances we've made in
understanding the objective material
world we've made by,
by with a tremendous amount of effort,
removing that tendency to see things in
an animated way from our collective
perception and,
and working diligently to come to terms
with the fact that there are ways of
treating certain phenomenon that aren't
animated,
that work better.
It's very,
very difficult for us.
And that's why,
for example,
we really didn't come up with a science
based technology until about 500 years
ago.
We really had to work against our own
instincts and we still done the
tremendous damage because to the degree
that we now perceive the world as
objective and material and sort of dead
in a sense,
it's also,
it's also being deprived of meaning and
people really suffer for that,
you know,
because motor people can certainly say,
given our understanding of both the
nature of reality,
is it reasonable to propose that
anything truly has meaning?
That's a very difficult question.
I would say don't give up on a too,
too quickly.
Okay,
so here is,
here's some natural categories of
apprehension.
So there's the dominants Archi,
that's for sure.
And that's the social group.
That's actually what union called the
animus.
Leaping ahead a little bit to the,
to the,
to the young new portion of this.
Um,
of these lectures,
the,
the dominance hierarchy is basically
what modern social constructionists
called patriarchy.
And it's often symbolized by an adult
male.
And that can have two aspects,
positive or negative because you know,
you're the of your culture and you're
also a victim,
so to speak.
It preys on you and pushes on you and
shapes you and molds even takes taxes
from you and finds you.
It doesn't let you do things.
But on another hand,
here you are in this university and
you're not starving to death and you can
all communicate and it's pretty painful.
So you know,
there's,
there's the great father,
so to speak,
bifurcated into two elements.
Pause to the negative.
And I told you the other day that that
was a little cirrus and that's who he
represented for Egyptian mythology.
He sorta standing on a pillar and a
representation to the right,
which is kind of an odd Christian
representation.
You have gone too far there in the
middle.
He sort of encapsulated inside Mary and
he's holding a figure of Christ and
everyone in the thing open to say
everyone on the doors to sorta looking
at Christ.
Um,
so there's the father in the middle
there and the father.
In the middle there is and on this side
you have what's essentially the son,
son and sun at the same time.
That's horace there and it's priced
there.
There's equivalent figures,
another religious and puzzled logical
systems.
And then on the right you have isis and
isis is related to Mary,
especially in this image because Mary is
basically portrayed there as the mother
nature that incorporates culture,
that's holding the individual.
It's a brilliant representation.
Most of them are.
The one on the right is a spectacular
representation because it sums up the
existential situation of human beings in
one sculpture and that is that well all
around us is nature and nature gives and
takes away and nature gives rise to
culture and culture supports us and
while it supports us we suffer and
hopefully we suffer and can manage it.
And that's why everyone is gazing at the
figure in the middle,
who's basically accepted the
inevitability and necessity of his own
death as a precondition for life.
So it's an amazing representation under
brilliant,
brilliant work of art.
A lot of that west elaboration of these
earlier Egyptian ideas.
There's awful lot of similarities
between the mythological representations
of horace,
for example,
and of Christ.
Here parallels are many,
um,
that makes people often cynical about
say the claims of Christianity.
But that's foolish as far as I'm
concerned,
because what both of these
representational systems,
0.2 is something deeper,
way deeper way underneath both of them
manifests itself in many forms.
So,
so this is the persona fine
representation.
So Mother Nature,
father culture,
and the individual.
Okay,
so now imagine that that's sort of your
primary as a crime made.
Who's striving towards linguistic
representation.
That's kind of what you've got to work
with as far as you're concerned.
That's the primal structure of the
cosmos.
So there's you,
that's the individual.
There's your mother and nature,
there's your father and culture,
and you are,
that's what the rates,
and that's what you've got to work with
to begin with.
Okay?
Now you know what?
Evolution is a conservative process.
And so what that means is that it's not
a radical renovated.
Usually what evolution does is cobble
something new onto something old.
Well,
the oldest conserve.
So for example,
you have mechanisms way down in your,
in your neurological systems that enable
you to do things like detects snakes
with an incredible rapidity and jump out
of the way it goes.
Or reflexes,
same reflexes,
similar reflections that are operative.
Say when you put your hand on a hot
stove and jerking away before you even
know it's hot.
So the reason you have,
the reason you can do that is because
your body has conserved incredibly
primitive neurological loops say will be
jerk your hand away from the stove that
only run from your hand to your spinal
cord and back.
So they're super fast,
but you know,
they can't do much.
They can jerk your hand away,
which,
which is enough.
If it's burning,
it's like it's a good thing to have
conserved.
So human beings as they evolve,
cognitively started out with this social
cognitive architecture that,
that they interpreted the world through.
And you can see why this would be partly
because,
well,
we do live in intensely social
environment.
There's always been mothers,
there's always been farther.
And then you add to that the human fact
that we have this unbelievably long
developmental period where we're
incapable,
fundamentally and capable of taking care
of ourselves.
Right?
So you know,
when something like that a moose calf is
born,
it's like three minutes later it's
wandering around in a full shows up.
Can,
you know,
it can run beside it's mother.
It's like human baby just lays there for
like a year,
you know?
And part of that is because it's,
you may not know this,
but for a mammal of our size,
we should have a gestation period of two
years.
So when those of you who are women have
children in the future and you know at
nine months you're pretty damn sick of
this,
you might well thank the structure of
the cosmos that you don't have,
you know,
15 more months to go because that's how
long the baby should remain in utero.
The reason it doesn't is because its
head grows too fast because we have this
big brain and so there's this weird
evolutionary arms race between the
mother's body and the pelvic girdle and
the head size of the infant.
And the way that's all sorted itself out
is women's hips are still narrow enough
so they could run,
cause if they were any wider,
they'd have a hard time running and the
baby is born at nine months instead of
24 with the compressible head because
baby's skull bones aren't put together.
And so when they pass through the birth
canal,
their head can be crushed and quite a
lot so that,
you know,
hopefully they live.
So anyways,
we have this incredible period of
dependency after that.
It's abject dependency for the first
while.
But then you're really not,
I don't know how long it takes people to
really get up and going.
It's like,
well 18 we'll say,
but of course that's complete rubbish.
It's more like 30 so there's a very long
dependency period and so that's all the
more reason why we would tend to view
the world as you know,
mother,
her father and then expand that owns
into our conception of the cosmos and
cure here seems to be how people did it.
So it's complicated association to
manage.
But I think the best way of managing it
is to think of the figure of Mother
Nature and that that would be narrow
here with the Isis.
They're now,
nature is a funny thing because I don't
want you to think about nature of the
way that modern people think about
nature.
I want you to think about nature as that
which lurks outside of culture.
So imagining the typical
tribal scene or let's say in the typical
rather primeval a village or gathering,
there's a domain that people inhabit
that they're sort of comfortable with.
That's where all the people are.
That's where the dominance hierarchy is.
And then that sort of surrounded by God
only knows what,
like the outside world,
the barbarians,
the darkness that eats the sun when it
goes down at night,
all the things that are foreign and
uncomfortable or outside of that circle.
And that's nature.
What's outside of culture is nature.
And so nature is the unknown.
And then what's inside is culture.
That's the known.
And that's actually turns out to be
weirdly enough,
even though it's a worldview that's
predicated on its underlying social
cognitive structure,
it turns out to be a worldview that's
unbelievably useful because it happens
to map onto the structure of subjective
experience extremely well in that
wherever you go,
you're viewing the world through a
cultural lens and you're usually
encapsulated in a culture as well.
You virtually,
it's virtually impossible now to go
anywhere where culture isn't with you
and around you.
I mean you can do it from time to time,
but even if you manage that,
it's still inside you in,
in,
in.
It's,
it's,
it's coated in the way that you behave
and it's structured the way you perceive
things and think about them.
So even if the outside world is devoid
of cultural artifacts,
doesn't matter cause you're a cultural
artifact right to your court.
Despite that.
And it's the incorporation of the
culture that allows you to maneuver and
live and act and do that somewhat
successfully.
Despite that,
despite that you're enculturated and
embedded in culture.
Nature can pop up and disturb you pretty
much at any moment.
And that happens when whatever it is
that you're doing doesn't work.
And so the way that that humanity
naturally perceives the world and
symbolizes the world is as a place
that's basically composed of culture and
culture is where you are when things are
going according to how you want them to
go.
That's sort of the definition of
knowing,
right?
It's,
it's not knowing a set of facts,
it's knowing how to behave so that the
ends that you're pursuing get acquired.
And that's more important in many ways
that knowing facts,
facts may help you do that.
But they been,
they may not too.
So there's,
there's,
there's the place you are when you know
what you're doing and you get what you
want.
And then there's that other place that
parks up all the time where you haven't
got a clue about what to do.
And that's the place that it's like a
transcendent place and that's nature.
And the Trans seven places where all the
mysteries of life comes from,
the things that you cannot handle,
the diseases,
the illnesses,
dad,
disappointments,
frustrations,
all the things that knock you for a loop
and make you tumble underground.
And that's nature.
Nature,
like a predator.
And it's a strange place nature because
on the one hand it gives,
because nature is the source of all
things,
given that it's the source of all new
but on other hand it takes away because,
because it surrounds you if,
because it transcends your knowledge,
it's eventually what,
what kills you.
So people have a very ambivalent
relationship with nature.
Andy and Andy with nature because of
it's because of it's bifurcated and
paradoxical
existence.
Culture's the same way.
I mean in formal logic,
a thing can't be one thing and it's
opposite at the same time.
And these mythological categories that
are derivatives of social cognition,
things are what they are in their
opposites at the same time,
just as you're a beneficiary or a victim
of culture and a beneficiary and a
victim of nature.
So now the reason,
part of the reason I'm telling you this
is because it's very complicated to
grasp,
but what's what's happened with you
neurologically in part?
Is that the part of your brain that that
evolved to deal with things like
predators and dangers.
You know,
things that are emanating from nature
that would directly threatened you once
those things became abstracted so that
they could handle,
became sophisticated enough so that they
can handle abstractions instead of
dealing with things like Predator,
a,
Predator,
b or Predator,
see your dangerous situation.
A,
they got sophisticated enough to deal
with the class of those things.
And so human beings,
instead of perceiving a dangerous animal
or a dangerous place,
started to be able to perceive danger as
such and to conceptualize danger as a
class of events.
But the same circuits that were
originate that originated to do things
like take care of,
you know,
to make sure that you knew where the
snakes were coming from are also the
circuits that now enable you to
conceptualize danger in the abstract and
to,
you know,
to deal with it one way or another.
Potential future danger,
danger.
Now the fact of danger as an existential
reality,
all of that only human beings can
conceptualize the class of all dangerous
things and part of that's associated
with nature.
So,
so there's the,
there's the domain of nature outside the
domain of culture.
It's like an ocean surrounding an
island.
And then there's you standing on an
island islands nice and secure.
It's a very standard mythological
representation of the cause was by the
way,
there's culture and there's nature and
there's you,
and that's the,
that's the architectural situation of
the human being.
And that's essentially our reality.
And it's,
it's a reality.
It's not merely objected because it's so
tied up with life and with other people
and with their own essential being.
Here are some,
now we can,
we can move from the sort of underlying
domains of nature of the unknown
culture,
the known and the individual.
And then we can start to put some
symbolic flesh on those bones.
And this'll help us when we get into
discussions of psychoanalytic theory
because the analytical psychologists
like yoga and the psychoanalysts like
Freud was very,
very interested in the images that were
produced by what they regarded as the
unconscious mind.
Now,
your most direct contact with those
sorts of images would come from two
sources.
One would be your dreams,
and the other would be the stories that
you're exposed to,
both ancient and new,
because those stories are full of
mythological motifs.
I mean,
it's very weird.
You know,
in recent years,
the most expensive artifacts that human
beings produce virtually maybe with the
exception of plants that fabricate chips
are movies,
visual representations of mythological
themes.
So for example,
the marvel movies,
iron man and those sorts of movies in
the avenger,
those are among the most expensive
things that people have ever created.
And you know,
when you say,
well there's,
there's obviously a profit motive
underlying that.
Well,
he,
yeah,
it's not a very intelligent analysis.
The point is,
is that people are still devoting a
staggering amount of effort to
representations like that.
And everybody goes and watches the,
so just for an example,
you know,
um,
in the avengers movie,
there's all,
I can name half a dozen mythological
motifs that,
that are embedded in that.
So for example,
iron man is nell chemical symbol cause
he's,
he's turning into gold and iron turns
into gold as far as the agent alchemists
are concerned.
That's part of its moral progression
towards perfection.
And his suit represents that cause it's
gold even though he's in the iron man,
he's also ICARUS,
right?
Remember,
ICARUS flies too close to the sun and
then plummets to earth.
So of course,
um,
iron man does that when he's in
countering the thermonuclear explosion
that eventually wipes out the,
you know,
the demonic aliens that are pouring
through the portal in,
in time.
So in the thor movies,
that's a hostile brothers motifs.
So there's thor and Loki that's like
kate enable or Christ.
And Satan's the same motif and it's
representative of the sort of eternal
battle between good and even evil that's
going on in the background of human
consciousness and like it's on and on
and on.
These movies portray these symbolic
realities for us and we're so hungry for
them that will line up and pay to watch
them.
It's very strange if you think about it,
you know,
there's,
there's not many forms of activity that
you will do that for.
You know,
and they're very informative,
those movies.
But you know,
you don't generally line up and pay for
lectures,
movies,
man,
you'll go to those for fun.
It's like,
it's very strange behavior,
especially when you look at what the
things are represented.
Everything that Medieval Christians for
example,
you know,
got exposed to in the Catholic Church
and in the mythology that went along
with that.
We go to movies and see,
so the movies set up the same way at
churches,
right?
There's seed rows and rows of seats and
all of a mythological actions at the
front and it's bright and there's music
and it's exactly the same thing.
So here's some symbolic equivalents.
And the reason you might think of a
symbol as something that represents
something else,
but that's not exactly the right way to
think about it.
These symbols in this sense are elements
of this domain.
So they're,
the domain encompasses a tremendous
number of phenomenon,
and these are some of the phenomena.
So there's nature nature's the
unconscious.
Why?
Well,
it's beyond you,
your unconscious mind.
That's not you,
that's nature inside you.
It does what it wants.
It'll do all sorts of things.
You don't want it to want what don't
want it to do,
and there isn't much you can do about
it.
And all you have to do is notice all the
stupid things you've done in the last
six months to understand to what degree
you're in the grip of the unconscious.
You know,
maybe you fall in love with someone and
you don't even like the,
I mean,
what the hell is up with that?
And there's nothing you can do about it.
You'll act like a moron.
Just like everybody,
every human being who's ever lived,
acted like a moron when that happen to
them.
So you're gripped by the darkness.
That's nature too.
That's what lurks outside the campfire.
It's like the terrible things that prey
on the unwary and of course that's true.
That's why it's not just symbolic.
He's things aren't just symbolic.
There are monsters.
You know,
parents will tell their children when
they have a dream,
while there's no such thing as a
monster.
It's like,
and then you know,
then they'll tell them not to ever
approach a stranger on the street
because God only knows what will happen.
It's like those two things do not go
together.
They're either monsters are,
there aren't.
People are so damn afraid of them still
that you know,
they torture their children to death
with,
with threats,
with the idea of threats that don't even
exist.
Like the probability that a given
challenge could be abducted by a
stranger is so close to zero that you
know,
you might as well not even bother
thinking about it.
It's almost always a,
you know,
a divorced parent that comes along and
grabs them and runs off with that,
you know,
well it's a custody if it's a custody
dispute issue.
Most of the time,
hardly anybody gets abducted by
strangers.
Why would they want your child?
Nature has dark.
This other element too,
which,
which you sort of hear about it at a
funeral where its ashes to ashes and
dust to dust,
right?
Nature is the thing you emerge out of
like poof,
there you are.
You're born and you weren't around
before and then you know 50 60 70 years
give or take a decade.
You're going again.
What did you come out of and where do
you go?
Well that's nature from a symbolic
perspective too.
It's out of nothing.
You come in back to nothing.
You go and it makes absolutely no sense,
but it doesn't matter because that's
what happens.
So that sort of nature as as the
unconscious and the devour and then
there's the great mother,
the Queen,
the Matrix,
the matrix,
the container,
the Cornucopia.
You know what a Cornucopia is.
It's one of those things that you see at
Thanksgiving.
We're thing,
it's got this point at one end and it
opens up into a kind of a big circle.
It looks like a horn.
It's made out of wicker.
And things pour out of it.
It's like what is that thing?
Well,
it's,
it's a Cornucopia and it's a,
it's a representation of the,
of the portal in a sense that everything
flows out of.
So you can think about it in some ways.
You ever watch those time lapse
photographs of a flower opening?
Of course he have,
you know how it sort of comes out of
nowhere and manifests itself.
That's what the Cornucopia is a
representation of the place from which
all new forms constantly emerge.
And that's what you're supposed to be
thankful for it Thanksgiving and you
should be thankful for it.
It's a pretty be a pretty dismal world
effects start happening.
And then there's this,
the object to be fertilized,
the source of all things that he come to
the pregnant,
that,
that kind of helps explain why the,
it's the,
it's the representation of the feminine
that was used to represent the unknown
because I'm now known as the place that
all new forms emerge from and that makes
it fundamentally feminine.
So
that's one domain of
unconscious symbolism.
Things get assimilated to this too.
So,
for example,
the strangers part of the unknown,
strange idea can be part of the unknown,
the emotional.
And that's because emotion overtakes
you.
You know you're at a movie and all of a
sudden poof,
you dissolve in tears.
It's like it wells up from,
from where?
From from the unknown interior and
possesses you.
And at the same time it does with
everyone else in the movie or you know
everyone else who's tuned in,
who has some feelings.
So other representations of the same
domain,
the foreigner as a person who comes from
foreign lands because they're
contaminated with things you don't
understand.
And sometimes that can be terrible
because the thing they're contaminated
with,
especially in human,
in the dark recesses of human history,
the illnesses,
I mean God only knows where the great
plague comes from,
but we know that it came on ships.
And so people left Italy because that's
where the plague seemed to first
manifest itself.
They laughed,
they went somewhere,
picked up some new rats,
came home,
we'd like poof.
A third of Europe was dead.
It was even worse when the Europeans
went to the new world.
Right?
Because as soon as the new world datas
shook hands with the,
it was like bang,
95% of them died in the next 50 years.
So the idea that the foreigner is
contaminated with the unknown,
that's a nontrivial Ikea.
And if it isn't,
you know the pathogens they carry that
it's the damn I,
he is to come sneaking into your culture
and just blow it into bits over,
you know,
a fair number of decades is something to
be terrified of.
You know,
by the same token,
there's incalculable wealth has been
generated culturally and materially as a
consequence of the intermingling of
human beings from all over the world.
So it's another one of those situations
where it gives with one hand and it
takes with the other
hell death and the grave
mood
ruler of the ninth and the mysterious
dark matter,
matter matrix,
mother,
same root words and the earth mother
earth.
So those are all those,
those,
all those,
all those images are related to the same
under underlying well of meaning and
not.
That's a representation of that which is
always beyond you from which all new
things coming to which all things
return.
That's the unknown.
Artists are very good at representing
this sort of thing.
This is quite nasty.
So these are your basic,
you know,
hell like monsters devour written other
monsters,
which maybe I could actually be a good
thing.
So that's,
that's,
that's a representation in some sense of
the war of everything against
everything.
You know,
the old idea about nature being red in
tooth and claw and everything,
devouring everything else to keep to
keep existing.
And a representation too of the sort of
pain is phrase that goes along with a
life of,
it's even quite peaceful.
Nature's a vicious place and,
and you have to contend with it and you
don't know what it's up to you.
And it's virtually impossible to keep up
with it in,
in Alice,
in wonderland,
Mother Nature's there and that's the red
queen,
the Red Queen.
And she's the one who's always yelling
off with their heads when they're trying
to play croquet.
It's like,
really,
you know,
that just doesn't seem civilized.
And,
and,
and it's,
it's,
it's the red queen who sows to Ellis in
my kingdom.
You have to run as fast as you can and
just to stay in the same place.
That's a good definition of life because
nature is always transforming.
This is Kelly is not the devour,
it's a Hindu representation and a,
well she's quite the character as you
can see.
Um,
I can tell you a little bit about the
image in the middle so that you've kind
of have some sense of what this,
like religious images are often trying
to represent
these fundamental realities that I've
been describing,
these underlying structures of
perception and cognition.
So Kelly hears it's kind of thing.
She's a representation of all the things
that you should run away from screaming,
which is a good category.
It's like the category of monsters and
horror.
And so let's investigate her.
So first of all,
she's a spider.
That's,
she has eight lanes.
You know,
people don't like spiders much cause
they were trying to poison us and they
web,
we're spin webs and capture the unwary
and then devour though.
So,
so she didn't this web fire,
that's the kind of call them on the arch
rounder and the fire is full of skulls.
You can see the skull,
it's inside the fire.
So it's like,
uh,
it's like a web of flaming skulls.
You know,
it doesn't get more awful than that.
Read it.
And then her hair's on fire and she
wears a headdress of stalls.
And then she's brought a few weapons in
case you're not already terrified.
And then she,
she often has the tongue of a tiger of,
oh,
I don't know if she does it,
match the image.
And then often there's a snake wrapped
around your waist.
But in this case it's not a snake.
You see those sort of coyly things
around your belly to belly and sunken.
That's cause she'd just be burst to the
guy that's two standard and she's
devouring inviting a test sites.
So that's Kelly.
And it's a representation of everything
you really don't want to mess with.
And you should be very,
very careful about if you make the
proper sacrifices to Kelly,
well then maybe she'll show you her
benevolence side.
And that would be a really good thing.
And you know,
people have been making sacrifices to
God's forever and God to try to get them
to stop,
you know,
okay.
Doing this sort of thing.
And you know,
it's very easy for modern people to
think about that as a superstition,
but it's not a superstition.
It's one of the most fundamental
discoveries of mankind.
And the discovery was if you let go of
something that you value now,
maybe you'll get something better in the
future.
It's like that is that,
that's the discovery of time.
It's,
it's a phenomenal,
it's a phenomenal achievement.
And human beings are the only people who
discovered it consciously.
Like bees make honey and they store it
up for the winter,
but probably they don't know what
they're up to.
But human beings can understand that a
terrible fate might confront you,
but if you make the right sacrifices
now,
you'll propitiate faith and you'll,
you'll survive and thrive into the
future.
And that's why you're all here at
university instead of while I'm,
I presume you did a real shortage of
partying,
but at least you're not doing it right
now.
You know,
you're making sacrifices to be here.
And the idea is that if you sacrifice
your valuable time,
the time of your youth now that the
fates will smile on you in the future
and then you know you,
if you would,
didn't believe that you wouldn't be
here.
So you believe it and you act it out.
Do you understand it psychologically and
conceptually and archaic people
understood it practically and
dramatically,
but it was the same thing.
You better make sacrifices and hope that
you can turn this into it's benevolent
counterpart.
Well then there's culture.
This is another domain of symbols.
It's a,
it's a very attractive domain of symbols
mean to the degree that you,
you're an Aficionado of a sports team.
You're,
you're tangled up by your,
your symbolic longing for a place within
a culture.
And it's,
it's so tied up with your psychological
being that you will act like the team is
you.
In fact,
one of the weird things about human
beings is that they'll often celebrate
the victories of their heroes or their
teams more intensely than they would
ever celebrate anything that ever
happened to them.
I mean,
how often do you see people at work,
you know,
throw their hands up in the air and then
run out in the hallways and dance around
because something good has happened?
It's like it never happens,
but if it's a football game or a hockey
game,
people will paint up their faces.
And when there's a goal sport,
which is a symbolic act two,
right?
Because you know,
human beings like to hit the target.
There's a sexual element to that,
but there's also an element of hunting
and there's an element of specifying
your target and achieving it,
you know,
and doing that cooperatively with all
the other people on your team
competitively in relationship to the
other team.
It's real little microcosm.
The point is,
is the symbolic elements of that'll grab
you just like you're a primitive
tribesman and you won't even notice.
You'll think,
oh,
I'm just having a party because my team
won.
It's like,
yes,
you are some cute your creatures.
So you know,
all the teams they have their,
their,
their tribal logo is essentially,
you know,
and,
and all the iconography that goes with
it.
And they're treated almost as if they're
sacred objects by people who are the
fans.
You know,
they'll go look at the Silver Cup and
they're happy as it comes to their town.
It's like,
don't be thinking you're not
superstitious,
you know,
it's just that our modern superstitions
are invisible to us and we don't notice
they're there.
It's like you're superstitious,
right to the court.
And human beings have always feed
culture,
superego,
Freud's categories,
id,
ego,
superego,
map quite nicely onto nature,
individual coaching.
So that's kind of interesting.
Became the patriarch,
the plow,
the Thalos order and authority and
tradition.
The wise old man and the tyrant dogma,
the day skype because it's illuminated,
it's illuminated.
The day skies is masculine,
it's symbolic nature.
Your country,
your brother,
the iron,
the heights,
and assess ancestral spirits and
activity of the dead
to the degree that you're patriotic.
No,
you're possessed by the symbolism of
culture and the symbolism of the known
you.
You would regard that as a virtue,
right?
Well,
what's more important to you?
Your own being or your family or your
own being or your family or your
culture,
which is more you?
Well,
it's not obvious and depending on the
situation,
people make different decisions.
As soon as it's war time,
everybody says,
oh,
my culture is more important than me off
they march.
You know,
even if it's world war one,
all they're marching to his,
you know,
continual death.
There's no,
you're gripped by these things in ways
that you just cannot understand.
Captain Hook,
he's a great representation of the
negative element of culture.
So Hook,
why does he have a hook?
Where does captive vocab,
the hooker
crocodile bit it off.
Right?
And what does the crocodile having its
stomach and what does that mean tide?
So what's bit old captain Hook's handle
off time is chasing him around.
It's going to take them under.
It's already got a taste of him.
And so he's terrified of that.
So he's an adult male,
right?
He's terrified of that.
He's a tyrant.
He's already lost a hand to time.
Now that damn crocodile,
that's that horrible Serpentini thing
that lives underneath the depths.
First chance it gets it going to take
the rest of these terrified about that.
It makes them into a tyrant.
Peter Pan looks at him.
He's the only adult being around.
Fundamentally.
He thinks there's no damn way I'm going
to be a tyrant who is chased by the
crocodile of time.
I'm going to stay a little boy forever.
That doesn't work so well.
Right?
Cause the only gets this tinkerbell who
doesn't even exist and he has to let
Wendy go off and be real.
You know,
it's,
it's an eternal story of not growing up
in the face of tyranny.
It's a story that won't go either.
And it's a story that people act out
like you wouldn't believe.
Okay.
Well,
and then there's the old man in the
talk,
right?
That's Stellan by the way,
that he's kissing.
I mean,
really think about that.
Stellan probably killed somewhere
between 30 and 60 million people.
That's a lot of people.
But nevertheless,
it's old man.
It's so gripped by what he represents.
It is sort of gold wisdom that misses
after the wall fell down that he,
you know,
he can't stop himself from worshiping
this thing that was so barbaric that
they're like,
it defies description.
The good old days you have.
Well they weren't so good.
That's a good representation of stuff.
That's for sure.
A terrible element of culture.
And that's patriotism gone wrong.
Stella.
Yes.
Everybody's family favorite.
I really liked the one on the right's
cause he sort of,
he's like the devil standing in the
flames of
love because it's very,
very accurate.
Yeah.
Stellan following Lennon,
that was quite a pair.
Then there's Hitler,
you know,
all the 20th century's other
manifestation of the horrible face of
culture
versus who is able to produce mass
hysteria is fall over.
He's the one who,
who represented for them everything that
was noble about so called area and
culture.
All of that was the consequence like
nature can do but so can culture and
that's why you know your proclivity to
identify with things,
to identify with groups and to identify
with states to identify with cultures.
It's like the greatest gift you have
cause it makes you civilized and
cooperative.
But it's also one of the most horrible
things about you because if it's an
activated property,
there's nothing more dangerous than you.
Well I told you about this but we'll go
over just briefly again cause it's very
important.
So this is the dallas symbol.
That symbol is dob.
Dow essentially means meaning,
but it also means the way it means a
bunch of things.
And Dow for the Dallas does what things
are made up.
It's what?
It's the underlying reality of things.
And for the Dallas that's more meaning
than it is like material or in some
other way you could think about this is
more like information than it is like
material.
And so the Dallas think that
that that
experience,
you can't say reality because it's not
the same conception.
That experience is meaningful and that
the meeting is the primary reality and
the meaning differentiates itself as an
emergence and it differentiates itself
first and to masculine and feminine
essentially into the structure that you
use to perceive reality.
That's culture and what it is that
you're perceiving.
And that's nature and that it's a lovely
conception.
It's different than the way people look
at the world in the modern world,
but it's,
it's,
it's parallel and I think it's,
if not more useful,
it's certainly equally useful because it
helps you understand and articulate
elements of your own experience that
can't be understood from a framework
that has a different underlying
structure.
So you know that sometimes you're
comfortable that things are going well
for you and you know that sometimes all
hell's broken loose and you fall through
the ice and you're dazed and confused
and maybe you won't get up again.
And you know that those are two
different places and that you'd rather
be in the former than the latter.
And you also know that there's certain
ways that you should act to make sure
that you stay where it's comfortable and
interesting rather than wandering off to
where it's like terrible beyond belief.
Not You could call that in some sense,
your innate sense of morality.
It's,
it's a,
it's a kind of intelligence,
but it's deeper than that.
And as I said in the other class,
the other thing that's lovely about the
dallas interpretation is that it's the
interplay between these two things that
constantly brings reality forth.
And then if you balance the property,
which is the aim of a property,
religious life from the Dallas
perspective,
then you have all the benefits of what
you understand and what you are and what
you're familiar with order.
And then you have the excitement of
having one foot in not unknown.
And it's a perfect place for human
beings to be because not only do we want
to stay with what we are and conserve it
if it's good,
but we want to continually transform it
so that it gets better and better and
better.
So I can give you an example of this.
I'll give you two quick examples and
you'll,
you'll understand what I mean.
So imagine you're watching a gymnastics
performance,
two of them and the first performer
comes out.
It's like the,
and the fruit.
The first performer comes out,
man,
this person is like perfect.
You can tell they expect $10,000 cause
that's what you need to master.
Something like working on these routines
and every single movement they make is
impeccable and the routine goes on for a
few minutes and then it ends in the
person's,
you know,
they're triumphant about it and
everybody claps.
And the judges are all like 9.9 out of
town.
And people are pretty happy about that.
And so that's,
we're all hooked into that because we've
seen someone demonstrate mastery.
And so we're thrilled about that because
it shows that that's what a human being
can do.
And we're human beings too.
And so,
you know,
Yay for us.
So then the next candidate comes out and
they've got a real problem because of
course what they have to face and
overcome his perfection itself.
If you might take,
well,
how in the world could you possibly do
that?
And so they get out there and this
performance is different.
It's got everybody on the edge of their
seats because they watched that person
go through.
They're absolutely perfect routine,
but they had one twist to it.
They push it so hard that you can tell
by watching them that every single
second of the performance,
they're like this close to disaster.
So they've taken their perfection and
they pushed it to the point where well
they're well,
they're competing,
they're improving themselves,
they're taking that risk.
And that's the sort of phenomena that
makes everybody in the audience go
absolutely dead quiet cause everyone's
on their edge of their seat thinking,
oh my God,
is this gonna work?
Is this going to work?
Are they going to pull it off?
And so no,
people are holding their breath and
they're,
they're tied right into it.
And then that person ends and you know,
they do their little tram foot landing
and everybody's on their feet,
rory.
And that's because they just saw someone
do this perfect mastery plus they pushed
themselves beyond that.
And so that's the proper way to play a
game.
You're not just playing it,
but while you're playing it,
you're improving your ability to play
it.
Okay,
here's a representation of that medieval
representation.
Here's the known and here's the explorer
pushing his head out past the dome of
the known for a long time.
That's what people thought reality was,
right?
It was this desk that everyone lived in
with this dome over top of it.
That's where the stars were.
And that's because if you go out in the
field at night,
well that's kind of what it looks like.
It looks like you're on a big desk with
them.
Don't over talk with it.
He's gone beyond that.
He's trying to understand what's outside
the realm of his comprehension.
And that's what human beings are like.
We're always poking her nose out past
our limitations,
trying to ministers the things that we
haven't yet mastered,
and there's real meaning.
And what's maybe that's the deepest
meaning that you can experience in life
is that is the capacity to take to
master something inventive,
continually extend your mastery at the
rate that you see fit at the rate that's
optimal for you.
And then there's the opposite of that,
you know?
So just as the great father has its
enemy,
the tyrant and the break mother has its
enemy the divine hour,
then the individual has a tendency,
and this is very interesting
representation from ancient Egypt,
this is,
and this is sick,
it's set is the Egyptian precursor to
the later Christian idea of Satan in
this representation,
it's good and evil that are,
this is like the tree of life here.
And what they're doing is sort of
spinning it back and forth.
And the idea here is that human
existence is a dynamic interaction
between these two forces,
one ending enlightenment and dried and
the other aiming at darkness.
And that's what that represents to
except in this representation,
it's the overcoming of the darkness
where that also happens in the Egyptian
stories but not in that particular
representation.
So you have the known or the unknown and
it's two elements,
negative and positive and you have the
known and it's two elements,
negative and positive.
And then you have the individual and
it's two elements,
negative and positive.
And the interaction between those
categories makes up stories
fundamentally.
And all the stories that you ever hear
about how it is that you should live or
shouldn't live are different
juxtapositions of those characters and
their interactions.
And the more archetipal the story,
the more clearly the case that structure
is.
So for example,
in the thor movies,
Loki and thor are sons of zoots,
right?
So Zeus is the great father and he
produces hostile brothers.
And that's the same that's echoed in
Christian stories by God and Christ and
Satan.
It's the same idea and candidate when
you see these hostile brother patterns
everywhere.
And that's because people have to
contend with what opposes the orderly
outside in the world when they're
contending against their opponents,
some of whom are corrupt and deceitful,
but also within themselves when they're
trying to set themselves straight and to
keep at bay,
all those elements of their own
character that seemed to work at cross
purposes to themselves.
It's a very strange thing about people,
you know,
we can't just tell ourselves what to do
were inhabited by all these strange sub
personalities that have a certain amount
of autonomy and they're off doing
whatever they want to.
At any given time.
And they're very difficult to bring
under control.
It's very hard to be the master of your
own house.
So I sub divided up reality for you in
one way.
And so for the time being,
we're,
we're done with that.
Now I want to sub divide reality up in
another way because you can't understand
what's going on in the heroic and
shamanic initiations and in the world
view that's encapsulated there
and
the implication of that worldview for
the understanding of phenomena like the
unconscious and the unconscious
symbolism without looking at the world
from one other perspective.
So here,
here's a decomposition of your computer,
let's say.
So first of all we'll imagine your
computer's working and so then you might
think,
well what is your computer when it's
working?
And then that's a hard question to ask
because it's while your keyboard,
cause you're clicking on the keyboard in
all likelihood and then there's the
screen or there's what's on the screen
cause you're not actually looking at the
screen,
right?
You're looking at what's on the screen
and isn't even clear where that is.
But the computer while you're using it
sort of collapses itself down into what
you're watching on the screen and what
you're interacting with.
That's the computer.
And then all of a sudden,
poof,
it stops working.
So you have an emotional response to
that,
right?
Like the monkey who's just seen a
Jaguar,
it upsets you.
And the reason it upsets you is because
you actually don't have a clue about
your computer.
And it either works well,
some of you more than others either
works and then it's a computer or it
doesn't work,
in which case God only knows what it is
or what you're going to do about it.
So this is,
this is a good example of how what you
understand can collapse into what you
don't understand because the computer
turns out to be an unbelievably
complicated thing and it can fail for
innumerable reasons.
And if you want to fix it,
then you have to take into account it's
insane complexity and start to piece it
back together so that it starts to
behave like the computer you want it to
be instead of like a,
you know,
old,
long oblong rock.
So what do you have to do?
Well,
I represented the computers,
that little black rectangle in the
middle and it's expanded it down one
level.
So your computer's obviously full of
subcomponents of all sorts boards and
chips and all the little things inside
of the electronic things that all of
which when they work you can ignore,
but when they don't work instantly
constitute a whole nest of snakes.
And so any of those sub components could
have gone wrong.
And then the sub components or me having
to even smaller parts of course in any
of those could go wrong.
And then underneath that there's the
element of properties that the mighty
parts have to contend with in order to
function.
And sometimes,
well sometimes weird things happen down
there.
So I don't know if you know this or not,
but computer chips have now got so small
that there's only some probability that
the electrons that are flowing along a
given wire,
we'll actually be in that wire because
the uncertainty principle specifies that
electron is probably here,
but it might also be somewhere else.
And at small enough levels of resolution
or high enough levels of resolution that
actually to become a problem.
So the electrodes can just get outside
the wires and that causes shorts.
So probably your computer isn't failing
because of some pathology at the quantum
level of reality.
But you never know.
Micro part might be not working property
component where you going to be working
property.
Ah,
but there's other ways of,
of the process of considering the
problem too.
You might say,
this is the last time I ever buy a
compaq computer and then what you're
doing is you're attributing because of
its failure to act like a computer to
the brand.
And then he might say,
well I bought one of those,
I bought a computer from a,
from an economic system that's still
somewhat pathological.
So you might say,
well it's a Chinese part,
for example.
And as a consequence,
the brand isn't reliable and the reason
the brand isn't reliable is because the
economic system isn't reliable.
And that's because the political system
isn't reliable.
So maybe the reason your computer
doesn't function is because the
political system that surrounds the
manufacturer doesn't function well.
So he ended up with a cheap part and it
doesn't work.
And so all of those,
as soon as your computer stocks being
what it is to you,
which is the keyboard and the screen or
what's behind the screen,
say that all of a sudden it turns into
all these other things that it could be
in order to get it working like a
computer again or even to replace it,
you have to contend with all of these
other multiple levels of reality.
So
there's two lessons from that.
One is,
well that's why you get stressed when
something stops working.
It's because when it's working,
it's doing what you wanted to do and
that's what it is.
The fact that it's doing what you want
it to do defines what it is.
But as soon as it stops working,
God only knows what it is.
You know,
cars are like that,
except they're even worse because with a
computer you can usually just throw it
away and replace it.
And you know,
maybe that's a couple of hundred
dollars,
but maybe something went wrong with your
car.
Well that's a complete bloody
catastrophe because not only does it not
function as a car and how it's just a
hunk of metal,
but you have to take it to someone who
you don't know to fix it.
And who knows what they're going to do
with it.
Like they might fix it,
but they might not,
or they might take something that
actually isn't wrong or they might
overcharge.
You are,
I mean,
there's a whole rat's nest that's
associated with having your car break
down and that tangles you write up.
It's funny because as soon as the car
breaks down,
then you have to contend with the whole
culture that surrounds the car and any
of the,
all of the pathology that might be
embedded in that culture.
Okay.
So one way of thinking about this,
uh,
computers like that manifests itself on
multiple levels simultaneously,
but so do people and so to all other
phenomena will stick with people.
For now,
you know there's a level at which you're
phenomenologically a parent and that's
the level at which we all see each
other.
I can see your front but not the back of
you or the sides of you.
And I can see your outside but not your
insight.
And I can see you,
I can't see your family that surrounds
you all the way.
If I was a chimpanzee and we were
looking at each other and I knew you
were a high status chimpanzee,
my body would detect your family because
I would know that if I messed with you,
they'd come after.
And so I would perceive your nesting in
the social group,
even though you don't,
you'd sort of manifest yourself to me as
as just the body.
But my,
my,
my physiology would be smarter than
that.
So
another way of thinking about the world
is like this,
and this is a very old symbol as well.
So this is like the tree of life.
So this is the Scandinavian tree of
life,
which is called him,
does Disneyland.
And then interestingly enough,
there's a Peruvian tree of life from the
Amazonian jungle.
So that's quite cool I would say,
because it goes what goes look
remarkably similar,
right down to the fact that,
see at the bottom here,
this is rooted in chaos.
So down here maybe you can see there are
snakes and the snakes are eating the
roots.
They're always doing that.
But there's water down there and at the
same rate that the snakes eat the roots,
the water makes the roots grow.
And so there's an idea that this whole
multi level manifestation of reality is
grounded in that chaos that constantly
renews itself and its Serpentine.
And then in the one next to it,
you can see there's the mountain air,
like there isn't in this representation,
but you see that big snake that's around
the mound,
it's biting it's tail there.
That's called a neuro growth.
So that's another indication of the idea
that order that's culture is surrounded
by chaos.
Chaos is representative by that,
that big snake.
And,
and I think in this one,
there's a snake.
There's a snake in the Scandinavian
world tree just like there is in the
tree by the way.
In Genesis.
Right?
So,
and then there's this tree which is
being drawn by a woman named Angelica
Gebhardt.
Sayer went to the Peruvian jungle and
ask the showman there about their
visions of the world and drew this
picture as a consequence of what they
told her.
And what you notice is,
well,
here's a tree and there's this big snake
surrounds it.
And so that's an architectural idea.
And so archetypical that,
you know,
the ancient scandinavians and the
Peruvian Shaman in the middle of the
Amazonian rainforest can have the same
vision.
And the vision of reality is associated
with that multilevel idea that I just
told you about.
You know,
how can the world be like a tree?
Well,
the world is like a tree that sprouts up
from,
from the tiniest places up into the,
into the grandest areas.
It's,
it has multiple levels of resolution.
And that's what this represents.
And it's a really lovely way of thinking
about things.
It's,
it's not a way that we think about them
normally and,
but it's relevant,
right?
Because what you are isn't just what you
present phenomenologically which is what
everyone else experiences.
It's all the microsystems that you're
made up of that are invisible and that
can go wrong and it has to be diagnosed
in fixed and then just like that you're
embedded in your families and your
larger cultures and so on.
And if there's pathology there,
there's pathology and you as well.
And so you are structured in this tree
like matrix of interconnections right
from the subatomic level all the way up
to the cosmic level.
It's all affecting you all
simultaneously.
And this is a very nice way of
representing that.
I'll show you one more picture and then
we'll stop.
My son drew this when he was eight and
he had a very well ordered psyche,
which I was quite happy.
But look,
let me,
let me show you.
I never thought it was amazing when you
came [inaudible] you see my office.
So first of all you have that's ordered.
Those are all mushroom houses for
reasons I really don't understand.
And all of his friends live in those
mushroom houses and they all have his
friend's name on them and they put out
little fires cause kids always draw
that.
He,
there's always a chimney with the fire.
Who knows why.
So that's order.
And then there's the line down the
middle,
like the Yin and Yang line,
and then another side,
here's nature and chaos,
right?
And then the tree of life grows right in
the middle.
So that's the sort of Jack in the
beanstalk tree of life,
what's happening.
You may see,
see there's a lady by the gear and then
there's another lady bump on the vine
and I guess that's him.
And he climbs up the tree of life in the
heaven because that's heaven up there
and then climbs back down and with
information.
And so what he's doing,
well he's barely order and chaos is
climbing up and down.
We turn all the tree of life to the
route of his ancestors and then coming
back.
So amazing.
If you listen to kids dreams and if you
watch what they draw,
you see them produce these sorts of
architectural things all the time.
And it's,
you know,
probably it's not exactly exactly
instinctual,
right?
It's like there's a matrix that has a
form that can be filled in by cultural
content.
I mean,
he'd heard Jack in the beanstalk and you
know,
we've watched Disney movies and read all
sorts of books,
and so he could pick up the patterns
from those things and manifest
themselves,
but it's still remarkable.
It's very difficult to,
oh,
well,
we'll account for it a bit more on
Thursday.